افاد مسؤول امريكي بان الرئيس جو بايدن
قال انه سيجري اتصالا قريبا مع نظيره
الصيني في غضون ذلك حذرت الولايات المتحده
الصين من اي رد فعل مبالغ فيه وقال مسؤول
كبير في الاداره الامريكيه انه لا يوجد اي
سبب على الاطلاق يجعل الصين تستخدم ما
يجري ذريعه لرد فعل مبالغ فيه او لممارسه
مزيدا من الضغط على تايوان مشددا على ان
المساعي الصينيه لتغيير وضع تايوان لن
تسني واشنطن عن استقبال اي رئيس تايواني
على اراضيها وقال ان واشنطن تواصل تبادل
وجهات النظر مع بيجين بشان مجموعه واسعه
من القضايا عبر قنوات دبلوماسيه متعدده
ورفض المسؤول تاكيد احتمال انعقاد اجتماع
في كاليفورنيا بين رئيسه تايوان والزعيم
الجمهوري في مجلس النواب كافن مكارسي
المنحدر من هذه الولايه بينما حث مسؤول
اخر على ابقاء قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه مع
واشنطن